did you know that Ben Affleck got a
chance to play his favorite character of
all time and what about the fact that he
has almost as many Academy Award wins as
he does Razzy nominations for worst
actor yes he's a multi-faceted performer
in more ways than one and we've got way
more fun fact like these you're going
behind the scenes of his many movies
that earned over a hundred million at
the box office most of us know of
Goodwill Hunting as Ben Affleck's Big
Break Affleck and his lifelong pal Matt
Damon wrote the script together and
later starred in the 1997 film Damon
began the script in a Harvard
playwriting class Ben Affleck joined him
and they ended up winning the Academy
Award for best original screenplay
Affleck was only 25 years old and
consequently he's the youngest person to
ever take home the coveted award the
first day of shooting the friends were
brought to tears watching Stars Robin
Williams and Stellan Skarsgard uttering
the words from their script honestly we
we would have been bawling too and we
would have shed even more tears when the
movie scored 226 million at the box
office and a 97 on Rotten Tomatoes now
Suicide Squad didn't do nearly as well
it's got a 26 Rotten Tomato score but
hey Ben Affleck was way way less
involved in this one so we won't fault
him plus it made a whopping
746 million so hey who cares about the
reviews In the End plus the folks behind
this 2016 movie were prepared for the
worst so prepared in fact that the
helicopter scene was the last scene that
they shot why well they didn't want to
have to delay any filming if cast
members sustained injuries while filming
that scene sounds like a bit of a
Suicide Squad Mission everybody was fine
though Argo was the first film that Ben
Affleck directed but didn't contribute
to the writing at all and while he's
made history as a writer it's clear he
has plenty of strength in directing too
Argo became a classic scoring 96 on
Rotten Tomatoes and raking in 227
million at the box office and Affleck
also starred in the film interestingly
the first three movies that he directed
scored a best supporting actor or
actress nod Gone Baby Gone the town and
Argo for Amy Ryan Jeremy Renner and Alan
Arkin respectively Affleck did some
amazing and unique work on this film he
had the cast live in the house where
many scenes were filmed for a week and
everything inside the house including
movies and newspapers were chosen to fit
the time period now it's clear that
Affleck is a skilled director but he
once postponed directing a film for a
very special acting gig the film he
postponed was 2016's live by night he
put it off to star in 2014's Gone Girl
because he was committed to working with
David Fincher who Affleck describes as
the only director I've met who can do
everybody else's job better than they
could and it paid off literally Gone
Girl took home
367 million at the box office and earned
an 88 on Rotten Tomatoes Affleck took a
risk to make Gone Girl but he was a
full-blown Daredevil when making another
film that would be Daredevil of course
but he didn't just play the titular
character to earn that title he actually
did some pretty risky stuff he wore
heavy contact lenses which almost
entirely impeded his vision meaning that
he was nearly entirely blind while
filming and that wasn't all his future
wife Jennifer Garner with whom he fell
in love onset accidentally kicked him in
the head while filming the kick was so
hard that he blacked out hopefully it
was worth it when the movie scored 183
million at the box office though it only
got 43 on Rotten Tomatoes 2016's Batman
vs Superman didn't do too well
critically either with a 29 Rotten
Tomato score it did however manage to
bring in a whopping 872 million at the
box office it seems then that all the
work that Ben Affleck put into playing
Batman was worth it and he put in quite
a bit of work he gained 20 pounds of
muscle for the role and got down to only
eight percent body fat that could not
have been a fun process so Affleck
figured he might as well get something
extra out of the deal he asked if he
could take the bat suit home after
filming The Producers said he could but
only if he bought it for a hundred
thousand dollars for obvious reasons he
settled for a picture with the suit
instead Affleck may have done Batman vs
Superman for some time in the bat suit
but he did Shakespearean Love For Love
literally at the time Ben Affleck was
dating fellow actor Gwyneth Paltrow who
played the leading role Affleck took his
role in the movie to spend time with her
oh how romantic it worked out for them
too the 1998 film has an impressive 92
Rotten Tomato score and earned 280
million at the box office now that same
year Affleck had a starring role in
Armageddon and while this may not have
been as of centric as Shakespeare in
Love Affleck made sure that love played
a role in this famous I love you scene
between Affleck and co-star Bruce Willis
Affleck made sure that this scene was
more emotional than it was intended to
be he wanted a major Blockbuster to show
this very raw emotional moment rather
than two guys acting tough in spite of
the circumstances he wanted to
circumvent the stereotype that showing
emotion isn't heroic or tough and it's
clear that director Michael Bay approved
of this Choice one thing they didn't
approve of about Aflac however his teeth
yes Affleck's teeth were replaced after
some scenes were shot and Bay allegedly
noticed that they looked like baby teeth
Affleck's new teeth cost twenty thousand
dollars and a week of eight hour days at
the dentist that's rough but at least
the movie earned 555 million it only
scored a 43 on Rotten Tomatoes but we
trust that that score would have been
far lower without those new more adult
looking teeth it's clear by now that Ben
Affleck is willing to undergo a lot for
a role but what he did for Pearl Harbor
may have taken the cake Affleck's afraid
of flying and he actually took on the
role of what else but a pilot for this
film now that's commitment it could
however be why he originally turned the
role of wraith Macaulay down it's a good
thing that he ultimately took the role
though even though it only scored 24 on
Rotten Tomatoes it introduced him to his
future wife Jennifer Garner for the
first time and it also scored 450
million at the box office so even if not
everyone loved the film plenty of people
saw it one person did not see the film
however Affleck's grandfather he said he
preferred not to relive the war He's
Just Not That Into You was quite a
departure from Affleck's typical roles
but it still managed to earn 181 million
at the box office proving that afflict
is even more versatile than we already
thought while the rom-com only got a 41
on Rotten Tomatoes it still has plenty
of loyal fans yet even its biggest fans
may not know that the author of the
novel that the film was based on May
made a cameo Greg Behrend plays the
efficient at Paige's wedding in the 2009
film a movie that did far better
critically was the 2010 crime drama the
town which had a 92 Rotten Tomato score
Affleck not only starred but also
directed this movie and he actually
liked to combine the two by directing in
his costume he wore his skull mask to
direct and co-star Rebecca Hall noticed
that this sometimes made it hard not to
laugh still the film made Zack Snyder
realize that Affleck should play Batman
because he could play an intimidating
character who was leading a double life
The Mask must have helped too though
this movie earned 153 million at the box
office while onset of Pearl Harbor
Affleck was offered the role of Jack
Ryan in the sum of all fears his co-star
Alec Baldwin had already played Jack
Ryan in The Hunt for Red October and he
encouraged Affleck to go for it he did
and the movie earned 194 million at the
box office at 59 on Rotten Tomatoes in
2016 Ben Affleck starred in the
accountant which he calls one of his top
favorites of his own performances the
others are Batman Chucky and Good Will
Hunting Holden McNeil and Chasing Amy
and Tony Mendez in Argo now this film
has something interesting in common with
Affleck though Anna Kendrick's character
discusses learning to count cards in
blackjack in real life Ben Affleck is so
good at card counting that he's been
banned from multiple different casinos
no need for gambling when you're in
movies that are in 153 million at the
box office like the accountant though it
also got 52 on Rotten Tomatoes 2017's
Justice League earned even more way more
it got 656 million at the box office
despite its not so great Rotten Tomatoes
score of 39 Ben Affleck was even
considered to direct the movie as well
as starring in it but the gig went to
Zack Snyder and later Joss Whedon so
which one of Ben Affleck's movies is
your favorite do you agree with him
about his top 5 best performances let's
talk about it in the comments and purple
see more videos like this one be sure to
like And subscribe to the things